welcome to this video playing squirrel
squirrel chespin much up from France and
yeah it's not going to play now now he
is ok I think I should play something
that I know for a change i really had a
bet bed run in the last couple of games
and well you didn't see them or I played
some warm-up games without any recording
and those were also terrible ok so we
have a an exchange rip with the d3 yeah
that's very very em gasps slow way to
play very conservative not even going
for a quick opening of the center ok I'm
trying to block all that see 585 and
that's very very slowly and b6 I start
let's start with that that's ok 9726 is
what I want to do but I must keep CFR
protected of course ok is he really
trying to play d4 him and maybe maybe
maybe what can can really do that i'm
not very well developed it's um of
course always a bit controversial as
blacks got the bishops do you really
want to open the position but ok if
you're very much add in development you
can consider it to to do to do it
against the bishops queen p 1 ok maybe
maybe going for before but before I
don't really feel at all
okay the night is supposed to go there
anyway so better do it quickly also
should take some sting out of d 4 as I
can exchange the night the NIDA arriving
there immediately 94 okay well maybe you
can take care but I Kayla I try to get
the Queen over to h5 maybe try to get
something on the kingside his queen is a
bit off on b1 so play on the King side
is not ridiculous and I hope yes but the
bishop isn't Bishop f three years Bishop
g4 a slight issue here I was I was
hoping that this is a bit distracting
yes he quickly decided to take the
permit I thought this should be this
should be some some sort of compensation
with this week structure okay all the
check first well rook f7 is a bit a bit
on a moon yes I give the check first and
then route to f7 now
yeah I don't know queen or queen h5
immediately now I can probably just take
on on have agent be okay yeah well I
don't I don't I don't think I better
hear anything but i hope that judge it
would be sufficient play with possibly
f5 coming against the kingside structure
the special bond c5 it might have a
useful role in controlling let's say dat
if it goes to be six but it does not
help in defense okay rook takes I guess
so just attacking f3
yeah how do I wow this looks risky
putting this rookie on on an unprotected
swear
okay now I'll come on let's take it
first I needed to do this I guess in any
case okay well now that have I have rook
h3 maybe I have something better but
drew cage three as possible it's also
just stroke f7 you kind of keep it keep
it simple approach they don't really see
why I shouldn't do that can play Queen
g2 maybe 22 g6 rook takes b7 something
silly like that might might just happen
you have to be seven pawn
I can play rook f7 no it's not it's not
totally totally stupid but Queen D Phi
if it looks like I'm in some trouble
after that
yeah I don't really see some see
anything else and he also has this check
here and Queen f7 k YF I have this play
on h2 I think what can just take here
okay didn't it was possible though just
taking him pretty sure maybe time
morning maybe this 95 to f3 or something
yeah this looks very fishy internment no
no one North freely right
just take me seven maybe there is
something better you cannot play 95 here
I can take age seven but I didn't have
anything to prevent it check
and I can take 83 can just take h3
amongst others but yeah I didn't see a
move really
check check yeah I have one second left
black4 fits on time yeah at some point I
started to play excellently really yeah
i mean this this looks just like black
should be ok i think but maybe there's
just this counter play and it's it's
fine i don't know brooke d 7 yeah this
is just very strong i mean he's just
playing this is a very strong manner I
mean he's rated like 1,900 but he's not
playing like that not at all I mean you
can also defend their 3 which is much
weaker this is so this is just very
tricky now for black I don't don't
really see how to play that I really
thought that I have enough counter play
at yeah i saw that Queen g2 is good for
white but what else is there i mean look
f 7 s what the computer wants to do but
it looks this is this is what the engine
suggests it just looks like terribly
passive yeah but maybe this is what i
need to do I mean if there is nothing
better yeah I gave this a this up roop
do you want me on this I also we can
take be seven but okay we wanted to get
the last piece into play i guess and i
don't really have a move this was like
the only idea that I had with 95 coming
the engine even points out the Dwight
can take on a FOIA okay well I couldn't
check think about that it's winning gym
check I can just take the rook but this
is winning as well Joe don't know he
played this very strongly and it wasn't
an engine or anything it wasn't cheating
if you look at it here with the stock
fish running here stock fish at some
many points even points out a better
moves for wide so it doesn't he didn't
just rapid use engine move so anything
it was was quite okay simply what he did
yeah I don't know it was it was simply
refuted this this idea with giving up a
porn maybe yeah maybe here Queen h5 or
yeah did fields I don't know I thought
that should have enough play against the
king is this how to believe that I
shouldn't have enough I mean the bishop
is just almost dead it's not related in
any way to the Kings side and still I
don't have anything here yeah maybe the
default is just them the D file is just
so much more important discovery money
out maybe maybe yeah while you played
this very nicely Jeff thanks for
watching